so what we need to do is learn to switch
on our acorn brains
so we can win this struggle going on
with the marshmallow brain that's the
beginning of becoming a long-term
thinker to recognize
that by nature we have this acorn brain
built into us
the question it really is how are we
going to switch it on
and i think to do that we need to
recognize that in society at large
there is what i think of as a tug of war
for time going on between six drivers of
short-termism
and six ways to think long-term the six
drivers of short-termism
are dragging us over the edge of
civilizational
breakdown the six ways to think
long-term
are taking us towards a long-term future
for people
and planet and we need to draw on
the six ways to think long this
cognitive toolkit for long-term thinking
that i mentioned before
in order to really switch on our acorn
brain and become better ancestors
now if you look at the six drivers of
short-termism some of them are quite
familiar like digital distraction or
political presentism
you know the short-term electoral cycles
some of them are deeper such as the
tyranny
of the clock because the invention of
the clock in the medieval period
is a key moment in shortening our time
horizons
time started being measured and sped up
it's been going on for 500 years by 1700
most clocks had minute hands by 1800
they had second hands and the clock
became the key
instrument of the industrial revolution
keeping those assembly lines moving
faster and faster today of course we've
got nanosecond speed
share trading going on which has brought
the future closer and closer to the
present
but each of those drivers of six short
termism is matched by
a form of long-term thinking